[Music]
6 44 here on a wednesday morning we
welcome you back here to the program
metro sheriff joe lombardo joining us
now for our morning cup of joe's segment
sheriff lombardo thank you once again
for joining us here bright and early on
a wednesday morning how are you
good morning john so uh leading up to
sleep last night oh
no sleep is sleep is overrated uh who
needs it right
uh it was a very busy election night
obviously leading up to election night
we talked to some businesses here in the
valley there have been some
reports around the country about
concerns about the
effects of the election and potential
protesting violence
did you see anything around the valley
did metro have to deal with anything
last night
no surprisingly we didn't um i was
we were basing everything off what you
heard and what you just
described and we thought we were going
to have some concerns with the
anarchists um just disrupting the
polling locations but thankfully we
didn't we had a you know very
comprehensive plan put in place
in conjunction with the secretary of
state and the attorney general and we
ensured that we had
officers available in case we were
called and thankfully nothing happened
so
that gives me some pride and you know
our community and
people how they deal with the what's
going on in the nation
so but yet we still have a couple days
to go obviously because
decisions haven't been completely made
and hopefully um
it's not contested and which causes uh
us some concerns
um and going forward so we're gonna have
all the resources still in place
to deal with it for the next few days
until we can finalize the vote across
the nation and
people make a decision how they're going
to act aside from this
potential issue that business owners at
least some of them had had brought up
what kind of security did metro provide
at the polling locations to more than
120 of them around clark county
yeah that's a good question so there was
concerns that we were going to
be oppressive if we were present and
people could see us there staged at the
polling location so we made a point of
staying
out of people's view but able to respond
quickly if needed
and so it was mostly just a drive-by
type
mode that we were in just to be aware
present
and able to respond in a in a timely
manner so um
other than that that that's that's all
she wrote basically we had a
department operations center stood up
similar to what we do with new year's
eve so we have a lot of resources
um to bear if needed via a phone call a
quick phone call we can
bring all those resources to play and we
had you know
internally uh the detectives were all
outfitted in uniforms in case we needed
to respond
in a timely manner similar to what we do
with other major events like new year's
eve so
but thankfully they were just bored and
we didn't have to go to that
uh go that direction they were they were
the only ones who were bored yesterday i
think given what was going on
let's talk about another issue we've
been covering recently this horrible
murder up on the east side of the valley
the death of michelle weissman the woman
who was riding her bike
pushed off by someone who's in a passing
car that person
died we know the driver of that van has
been arrested
i guess first of all what is the latest
from metro's point of view with the case
and
have have detectives been able to
pinpoint at least a motive of why this
tragedy even happened
yes um as far as the motive i'll answer
that question first
no other than just being idiots um it's
it's
actu it's a very tragic event and my
condolences go out to the
miss weissman's family it was senseless
it was every word you could think of to
describe it
so the the unique piece on this is the
driver of the van
had just been recently uh released from
prison i believe four months earlier
for violent crime and for so obviously
the
reform at prison didn't occur with this
individual and and
they attempted to uh do the same
uh event they did with the bicyclists
with miss weissman prior to miss
weissman but they missed those
individuals and they continued down the
street uh
apparently saw miss weissman and and hit
her
in the back area and knocking her to the
ground which we know that she
eventually died from her injuries and
then the
individual that affected the um
was thrown from the car because of the
force against miss weissman and
he eventually died too and then we were
able to get the
driver of the van in custody um
you know it it was a weird event when
the officers first arrived they didn't
know exactly what had
taken place and thankfully they were
able to piece it together
in a short period of time and do what
they do
so um now just an absolutely tragic
situation on the east side of the valley
we will uh we'll follow that case and
others
we do appreciate you joining us this
morning sheriff if you at home have a
question for sheriff lombardo
you can submit it on our website
8newsnow.com find out if it's answered
every wednesday we'll catch up with the
sheriff again next week